hey everyone so I'm extremely excited to
announce that I'm part of an amazing
campaign called the social media envoy
we have one goal in mind and that's to
help end malaria
did you know that each year there are
over 350 million cases of malaria and
over 1 million deaths mostly children
every second there are 10 new cases of
malaria and every 30 seconds another
child in Africa dies
bed nets cost only $10 and they can
protect two or more people as they sleep
at night for up to five years
the insecticide woven into the nuts can
make entire communities safer
on World Malaria day on April 25th help
us spread the word and and malaria